buongiorno ragazzi mamma mia che faccia
comunque ben tornati a quello che sarà
diciamo un blog settimanale ora non so
se riuscirò a bloggare tutti e sette i
giorni non so se a volte questo proprio
settimanale sarà di nessun troverete un
solo giorno se a volte invece saranno
piccoli punti di tutti e sette i giorni
della settimana non solamente di alcuni
di questi fatto sta che abbiamo iniziato
siamo qui e oggi sconosciuto sarà pronto
signori è appena successa una cosa
stranissima
allora ho ricevuto un invito a londra
per un evento al quale dovrebbe
partecipare anche la regina coeli data
la royal family
chicca come metto ciò che ciò in cavallo
l'armatura la spada che cosa si fa
vestirsi che bello grande mamma mia
scusatemi ragazzi mi sono appena
svegliato non mi dovrei mostrare in
questo stato per luigi origene di leggi
e di getto moreno sono stati invitati a
londra per un evento dove praticamente
sul red carpet
tra le varie star internazionali che ci
saranno ci sta pure la royal family
innanzitutto tu puoi venire seconda cosa
che come ci si veste
allargando lo scrupolo che luigi e possa
prendere un vestito che non mentre
quindi arrivato il momento di fare
questa cosa
salite sopra di me io non ci salgono fin
dall'estate va in fatto di poggiare la
camera perché sicuramente pesa molto la
telecamera oddio santo
oddio santo non ci possono se mi guardi
dall'alto lontano con la luce che mi
taglio in questo modo sembro magro
io devo uscire per andare ad allenarmi
devo fare qualcosa ad andare allenarne
del cece andare allenarmi cio pochissimi
giorni di digiuno ho fatto a ridurmi in
questo stato
ok sono in macchina e sto andando al
parco credo che correrò correrò
all'infinito senza mai fermarmi credo
anche che forse la cosa più
possa fare sia mettere questa mattina in
strada poi spegnerla tirare il freno a
mano tre nello sportello comincerà a
spingerla con tutto il freno a mano
finché non arriva a destinazione in
questo modo in quattro giorni riesco ad
arrivare al peso forma che cercavo
buongiorno come stai
cos'è sta voce ricevuto una telefonata
da un numero sconosciuto ma ama lo
sapevi già chi l'ha vistò disperato sos
salito sulla bilancia
io vado a incontrare la royal family che
sembra il cavallo da venere la regia me
monta sulla schiena senti io sto andando
ad allenarmi
secondo me la visa in tre giorni riesco
a fare una dieta sana e un'attività da
addestramento militare potrei riuscire a
farcela vino quantomeno la mia devo
l'ora di allenarmi al parco ragazzi ora
vogliamo all'evento a londra importante
e quindi ci è venuto a rompere le pappe
tutti non potevi rimanere grasso anche
oggi non potevi di soffrire degli
scompensi e quindi ora si deve rimettere
in forma che volevo dirvi che nonostante
le variazioni di piani e quant'altro o
una felpa che tra merita c'è una
situazione tragica del cerchio allora mi
sono pesato stamattina sono un sacco un
sacco di pandoro e panettone un sacco di
farne ventosissimo a londra insieme a
luigi ok io sono vicino a lui forse
saremmo vestiti simili e sembrava la
brutta versione si il completo anche se
in questo caso
sarebbero più da chiamare tipo pezzi di
stoffa che servono a non far disfare le
mie carni un allenamento e ho bisogno di
un aiuto perché tipo tre giorni per
buttare giu almeno 12 punti
devo fare un evento nel quale ci sarà
pure la royal family
la ventina di tappe se calcolate
derivata in forma battendo alcune mappe
100 anni dei faccio lo faccio un
attentato con un bottone esatto con la
reggina bomba tu puoi avvenire al parco
allora 39 3 dai bella ecco mi è arrivato
devo dire che per essere gennaio sesta
una bomba però son caldo che l'essere
bizzarro e l'aviazione cappellino la
cosa sembra felice come sembra 16 uno
scherzo
il ragazzo è incredibile è avvenuto
veramente non solo mi ha invitata al
parco ma è anche venuto al parco chi
vedo piero di entusiasmo io penso che
per un corpo da 78 kg faccio un giro
nella tua vita almeno mai che si tratti
da una scusa mi piace niente sono me
stessa ma non parla
se così in forma per la polla io sono
così in forma perché marrakech fa per
canzoni bellissime io vengo e corrotta
ma chi ascolti ma l'ha chiamato su
gemiti cosa ci fai qui bacall un
monopattino elettrico perché io guiderò
come gli allenatori olimpionici magari
manca qualcuno all'appello allora qte di
prova allora questo è un mezzo ormai del
presente
parliamoci chiaro non sa se no c'è
durante le vendite ai manufatti incerta
20 ragazzi purtroppo non ci sono alberi
nelle vicinanze
basta buongiorno ragazzi un già fatto
selvatico in tuta difesa no mi sto
riprendendo io
considerate che ho fallito io sono
arrivato qua da dieci minuti stiamo
osservando la linea
le volevo fare un agguato mi ero messo
là dietro parola cerca lei arrivata qui
si è fermata e se avremo lo facendo mi
sono scuri tipo esatto si poteva
sembrare inquietante siamo qui per fare
attività fisica perché guglielmo deve
andare a londra infatti va in giro
ovviamente non accelera perché prima di
seminare avvio chilometri orari
così pure io già partiti senza freni
occhio perché potrebbe esplodere ma
secondo te ci sono speranze di fare un
lavoro su ci sono sembrati il profilo
fisico nozze un monopattino vedo che va
benissimo chi sono certezze
cisano e sestese via levanna te che non
sono frenati mi sentirei così simpatici
nostro mezzo che abbiano ruote così una
velocità ancora io cometa che mi
rimaneva al doppio della velocità ma che
cazzo fai tu ragazzi 15 centesimi
mancini per 30 milioni per la malattia e
altri stanno tutti giù la avanza e io
l'ho 39 voglio permettermi di malattia
dicendo no grazie non succede niente se
mi prendo un attimo di pausa malattia
per tempo non ci nascondiamo di don vito
nascondiamo proprio che stavamo male e
poi staremo alla chiesa vantaggi cioè
giocarla switch provincia
ora di fatti dallo zio ottimo ma così
amici fanno i 222 aspettano vado a fare
io
ma quando non vorrebbe nel vivo
vabbè grazie grazie a questa malattia
io no ai capitolini di risveglio visto
che sarà il primo allenamento
1 parte anche l'unica che ci mettiamo in
quella zona di un po più appartata non
fate bastati allenarti nero no quando fa
il bambino di shining anni fa morire 33
posto tutta questa negatività che hai in
corpo di guardare siete pronti cir
conduzione delle ginocchia esatto con
piedi uniti con piedi uniti un po più di
ritmo voce volevi rimanere a casa o
sbaglia solo essere molto gentili nei
confronti del mio corpo non devo
forzarlo bravo però così la tormenti si
va bene siete pronti siete già caldi
vedo
e allora via di corsa un giro della
pista
va benissimo allora dovete riuscire a
mettere la respirazione all'interno
delle del vostro esercizio ragazzi
esatto ispirare dal naso destinare della
bocca sempre ci sei
ciao ragazzi un altro un altro ho detto
una bugia
sto notando già delle gambe pesanti qui
è possibile mai che ti stai comportando
meglio di tutti i laghi
ma attenzione perché già un pazzo ha
scattato mamma minisprint bravissime
giri
sento già più magro grazie ragazzi ok ok
pranzo giù a terra quattro di bastoni
noi stiamo sporcando tantissimo se
esatto sporcate testa dritta bravo
marchino perché non sei per niente
contento che lascia andare serve una gru
di fianco afferra la punta del piede
esatto e vado a strisciare dietro o
brava la linea che brava diventava
quanto la stessa cosa ho detto bravi
[Musica]
sentire qui il 4 cp de femorale
mi a lungo sulla gamba distesa
attenzione e nvidia monta c'è del
talento è in fermento con mese perché
tira fuori la terza gamba tutti sappiamo
che questo in pista perché sono più
bravo fino adesso ci stai ad esempio
sotto in bronzo la siciliana e lei è più
brava sempre energia energia del
movimento respiro ma siamo sulla spalla
mi stupisco perché è arrivato a scusami
vanno sarà una due pullman non perdere
riposo pausa saluti
i ragazzi piano piano si stanno
allenando anche se arrivano ospiti
inattesi
detto questo io adesso li metterò sotto
torchio ancora un pochetto e poi
scappiamo diciamo questa parte qui e ci
vediamo direttamente dopo il training
dai caldo ma ce l'hai sempre vinta ma
tutti si alzano e matta di questa
malattia tutto sommato non è male
merito dei benefici della malattia
però c'è un guardone un attimo certi che
anche ciò ma tale la prossima volta
volevo certo ma parlerò e su quelle
delle strette di zappi dai coltelli
non è che se io sto male ho visto il
malato sul letto detto vabbè dai quanto
accudisco al mio fratello in maniera
amorevole ma ieri s'è già gambero rosso
luce come qualche gambero rosso qualche
gambero
adesso glielo chiedo cambierò fatto che
per farlo come non voglio che esca tua
telefonino è tranquillo non correre però
neanche metterci tre ore sono negati a
chi di questa di elemento la linea è
entrata nel mutismo adesso dobbiamo fare
adesso andiamo diretti da noi a mangiare
una robetta dietetica posta allenamento
ok ma vuoi sapere il vero cosa questo
isolato riso non deve creare un po di
pollo è un con tornino di vero bello io
mangio e un pochino di queste piante
l'alito secondo io non posso venire
comfort e finalmente abbiamo trovato una
spesa non lo stato ragazzi vorrei
solamente dire una cosa la carne è
sabato il tuo comunque non ci fermiamo
mai io devo invece smaltire ragazzi
mentre vi parlo cammino in tondo cammini
in tondo che mino in tondo
niente oppure glielo faccio sempre basta
perché troppo fredda poi ritirato in
gestione possiate troppo per circa
lister corso a vedere il percorso della
casa ovviamente sperando che mi riesca
succedendo bravo bravo sarà il
fallimento
ragazzi niente sono un fallito prossima
seduta
non lo so non ho mai provato è il nostro
talent e lui vediamo se ce la fa seduto
l'ultima parte niente piedi a terra mio
nome mamma mia
stai lì non se li bravissimo buono
buonissimo gigante no ragazzo di ai
partito ottimo il trucco e parti di
mourinho non sei pronto a parma non
ultima se non ce la faccio
le acquisto 1 oggi gli arresti come dire
ci rivedremo presto ti stai nonna stai
sai non dai fastidio tanto ormai è
finito ma dovrà inventare di balzare m
si conclude così ragazze qualcuno di voi
nei commenti vuole darci l'opportunità
di girare a casa vostra
[Risate]
buongiorno ragazzi oggi e domenica sta
per salire sulla bilancia fino a che
cosa è successo
domani si parte molto meno tragica che
negli altri giorni cioè sempre grave
come situazione ma non altrettanto che
lei ecco ma non basta purtroppo non
basta perché con le puntate di cucina
buttata un po difficile riuscire a stare
in forma naturalmente loro mondo la
colpa si era buttata lo dica l'altro con
dai mi sto prendendo in giro da solo
cosa dico sera del giorno 2 come va la
pietà verso lo stato a casa di thomas e
raffaele and medicine vi dico solamente
che come regalo sotto andato a casa con
questo possiamo chiuderla quando mai il
vostro amore
[Musica]
[Applauso]